bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
pourquoi le maréchal haftar maintient
son blocus sur les champs et ports
pétroliers libyens coûté depuis le début
du conflit en libye entre la cyrénaïque
entre le maréchal à butaré et de et
monsieur sa rage et tripoli l'essentiel
de l'argent de la production pétrolière
libyenne était monté il ya un an à près
de 1 million 200 mille barils jour
c'est à dire la production que l'on
avait avant la guerre de 2011
tout cet argent 20 à tripoli diallo est
nu et cet argent tripoli sert à financer
entre le paiement des fonctionnaires ce
qui est normal sert à financer des
milices islamistes qui protège aussi sa
rage à tripoli
donc le maréchal ap star a décidé
d'utiliser le le pétrole comme arme pour
à assécher financièrement tripoli nodo
d'ailleurs la volonté de monsieur
erdogan et de ses miliciens syrie un
turco syrien de marché sur les champs
pétroliers et qu'ils se sont
obligatoirement arrêter quand le mari
chaîne syfy a indiqué que s'il
franchissait syrte et jouffre à l'armée
égyptienne interviendrait en libye le
maréchal utilisent cette arme
sachez que le mal la cyrénaïque ne
recevait que que 10% ne sait sommes
depuis cinq ans et le faisant rien donc
il y avait deux régions qui étaient
totalement impacté par un parent cette
manne financière qui n'arrivait pas et
donc mashal a décidé et sont des tribus
alliées au maréchal qui occupent les
champs pétroliers c'est pas l'armée
nationale libyenne sont des tribus
alliées au maréchal alors sinclair
dessus des 2 5 en libye at il dit ce
pardon oui je t'en prie avec la libye
dispose des plus importantes réserves de
pétrole d'afrique dont parlait de cette
manne financière ça représente quoi en
perte pour l'économie libye
mais elle représente des millions de
dollars chaque mois
imaginez imaginez lorsque lorsque le
baril était à 70 dollars imaginez ce que
représentait un million deux cent mille
paris deux jours parce qu'on parle en
barils jour
donc imaginez les sommes que ça
représentait donc une partie a été
détournée l'autre partie a servi à
financer les islamistes radicaux est
donc abandonné faut être sérieux il faut
arrêter donc ils utilisent cette arme
donc ça fait partie de la négociation
politique aussi qui va s'engager
1 le maréchal a deux atouts un il alarme
pétrolière 2 qui contrôle les deux tiers
du pays
aguerri contrôler le sud et le centre
c'est donc si on va vers une négociation
politique pour sortir de cette crise qui
dure depuis neuf ans neuf ans que nous
sommes en guerre en libye et il va
utiliser ses deux armes là dedans la
négociation s'agissant des négociations
les deux parties est un pays qui divise
et a plongé dans le chaos quand même
depuis assez longtemps et je pense que
monsieur erdogan puisque c'est lui qui
commande à tripoli insu personne d'autre
un monsieur erdogan qui contrôle dont
club migratoire elop terrorise tripoli
souhaite souhaite probablement prendre
le contrôle des champs pétroliers et
asseoir son autorité en libye est ce que
l'union européenne est ce que l'otan
sont décidés à le laisser faire est ce
que la russie ait décidé à le laisser
faire
je ne crois pas et donc on est obligé
d'aller vers une négociation politique
cette négociation politique on a failli
avoir déjà quatre ou cinq accords
politiques
rappelez-vous palerme rappelez-vous la
celle saint cloud rappelez-vous dubaï
rappelez-vous genève
rappelez-vous berlin et à chaque fois ça
a échoué pourquoi as à chaque fois que
monsieur s'arrache disait qu'il était
d'accord pour signer dès qu'ils rentrent
à tripoli des milices lui disais que si
ni reprenait de bateaux pour encore
retourner en europe et donc donc en ai
jamais en a jamais pu arriver à un
accord notamment depuis depuis trois ans
à cause de flins sachant que les accords
d
un terminé puisque vous parlez du
président turc a déjà taillé par nos
amis et soutiens qui le président turc
mais il soutient ses amis les frères
musulmans un monsieur erdogan est le
parrain international des frères
musulmans est donc tripoli et misrata
sont des bases deux frères musulmans
dont qui les soutient parce que les
seules entités des frères musulmans qui
reste sur la terre d'afrique se trouvent
en libye
uniquement en libye et en inde est
intervenu pour ces raisons là il est
attendu pour des raisons économiques et
rôle hier gazière il est intervenu aussi
parce que comme il a des problèmes
économiques et politiques importants
dans son pays
la guerre est pour lui une fuite en
avant merci à vous michel scarbonchi
ancien député européen consultante pour
le moyen orient